Patrick nunca abandonó su sueño de una educación superior.
Por la noche, después del trabajo,
navegaba por la red en busca de nuevas formas de estudiar.
Conozcan a Debbie.
Debbie es de Florida.
Sus padres no fueron a la universidad,
y tampoco ninguno de sus hermanos.
Debbie ha trabajado toda su vida,
paga impuestos, se mantiene a sí misma mes a mes,
orgullosa del sueño americano,
un sueño que no está completo
sin una educación superior.
Pero Debbie no tiene los ahorros necesarios
para la educación superior.
No puede pagar la matrícula.
Tampoco podría dejar el trabajo.
Les presento a Wael.
Wael es de Siria.
Conoce de primera mano
la miseria, el miedo y el fracaso
impuestos a su país.
Cree firmemente en la educación.
Sabía que si tuviera la oportunidad
de tener una educación superior,
para destacar sobre de los demás,
tendría más oportunidades de sobrevivir
en un mundo al revés.
El sistema de educación superior
excluyó a Patrick, a Debbie y a Wael,
exactamente como está excluyendo a millones de posibles estudiantes,
a millones de graduados de secundaria,
que están cualificados para la educación superior,
millones que quieren estudiar
pero no pueden acceder por varias razones.
En primer lugar, económica.
Las universidades son caras. Todos lo sabemos.
En muchas partes del mundo,
la educación superior es inalcanzable
para un ciudadano medio.
Este es probablemente el mayor problema
que enfrenta nuestra sociedad.
La educación superior ha dejado de ser un derecho para todos
y se ha convertido en un privilegio para unos pocos.
En segundo lugar, cultural.
Las estudiantes cualificadas para la educación superior,
que pueden pagar y quieren estudiar,
no pueden.
Porque... no es decente,
no es lugar para una mujer.
Esta es la historia de un sinnúmero de mujeres
en África, por ejemplo,
a quienes les está prohibida la educación superior
debido a barreras culturales.
Y la tercer razón:
UNESCO declaró que en 2025,
100 millones de estudiantes
se verán privados de la educación superior
simplemente porque no habrá suficientes plazas
para acomodarlos, para satisfacer la demanda.
Tendrán una prueba de nivel,
lo van a pasar,
pero aún así no tendrán acceso
porque no hay plazas disponibles.
Estas son las razones
por las que fundé la Universidad del Pueblo,
una organización no lucrativa, con matrícula gratuita,
una universidad que otorga títulos
para dar una oportunidad,
para crear una alternativa a aquellos que no tienen otra.
Una alternativa que será asequible
y ampliable.
Una alternativa que alterará
el sistema educativo actual,
abriendo las puertas de la educación superior
a cada estudiante cualificado,
independientemente de lo que ganan, de dónde viven
o de cómo los ve la sociedad.
Patrick, Debbie y Wael
son solo tres ejemplos
entre los 1700 estudiantes aceptados de 143 países.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
No necesitamos reinventar la rueda.
Solo vimos lo que no estaba funcionando
y utilizamos el increíble poder de la Internet
para llegar a una solución.
Nos pusimos en marcha para construir un modelo
que va a reducir casi en su totalidad
el costo de la educación superior,
y así es como lo hicimos.
En primer lugar, la universidad tradicional cuesta dinero.
Las universidades tienen gastos
que las universidades virtuales no tienen.
No necesitamos pasar estos gastos
a nuestros estudiantes.
No existen.
Tampoco hay que preocuparse por el aforo.
No hay límites de plazas
en la universidad virtual.
En realidad, nadie tiene que sentarse
al final del aula.
Y tampoco tienen
que comprar libros de texto.
Mediante el uso de recursos educativos gratuitos
y la generosidad de los profesores
que ofrecen su material
de manera desinteresada,
no necesitan libros de texto.
Todos nuestros materiales son gratuitos.
Incluso los profesores,
el asiento más caro del presupuesto de cualquier universidad,
les salen gratis
a los más de 3000 estudiantes.
Incluso los rectores, vicerrectores,
profesores y asesores académicos
de las mejores universidades como la Universidad de Nueva York,
Yale, Berkeley y Oxford,
se han unido para ayudar a nuestros estudiantes.
Por último, creemos en el aprendizaje recíproco.
Utilizamos este modelo pedagógico
para animar a nuestros estudiantes de todo el mundo
a interactuar y estudiar juntos
y también para reducir el tiempo
que nuestros profesores dedican a corregir deberes.
Si la Internet nos ha convertido en una aldea global,
este modelo puede crear sus propios futuros líderes.
Observen cómo lo hacemos.
Solo ofrecemos dos programas:
administración de empresas y ciencias de la computación,
los dos programas más demandados en el mundo,
los dos programas con más potencial
para ayudar a nuestros estudiantes a encontrar un trabajo.
Cuando aceptamos a nuestros estudiantes,
los repartimos en pequeñas clases
de unos 20-30 alumnos, para garantizar
que aquellos que necesitan atención personalizada la tengan.
Además, cada nueve semanas,
conocen a nuevos compañeros,
nuevos grupos de estudiantes de todo el mundo entero.
Cada semana, al entrar en clase,
encuentran los apuntes de la sesión semanal,
las lecturas recomendadas la asignación de tareas
y los temas de discusión,
que son la base de nuestros estudios.
Cada semana, cada estudiante
debe contribuir a la discusión en clase
y también debe evaluar la contribución de los demás.
De esta manera, abrimos las mentes de nuestros estudiantes,
desarrollamos un cambio positivo en la actitud
hacia las diferentes culturas.
Al final de cada semana,
los estudiantes pasan un examen,
entregan los deberes,
que los evalúan sus compañeros
bajo la supervisión de los tutores,
reciben una nota y pasan a la siguiente semana.
Al final del curso, realizan el examen final,
reciben una nota y pasan al siguiente curso.
Abrimos las puertas de la educación superior
para todos los estudiantes cualificados.
Cada estudiante con un diploma de escuela secundaria,
suficiente inglés y conexión a Internet
puede estudiar con nosotros.
No utilizamos audio. No utilizamos video.
La banda ancha no es necesaria.
Cualquier estudiante de cualquier parte del mundo
con cualquier tipo de conexión a Internet
puede estudiar con nosotros.
La matrícula es gratis.
Lo único que pedimos a los estudiantes
es cubrir el costo de sus exámenes,
100 dólares por prueba.
Un estudiante de licenciatura,
cursando 40 asignaturas,
pagará 1000 dólares al año,
4000 dólares por la carrera,
y para aquellos que ni siquiera puedan pagar eso,
les ofrecemos una variedad de becas.
Nuestro objetivo es que nadie se quede atrás
por razones económicas.
Con 5000 estudiantes en 2016,
el modelo es financieramente sustentable.
Hace cinco años, era una visión.
Hoy, es una realidad.
El mes pasado, recibimos el aval académico definitivo.
La Universidad del Pueblo está acreditada plenamente.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
(Fin de aplausos)
Con esta acreditación, es el momento de crecer.
Hemos demostrado que nuestro modelo funciona.
Invito a las universidades y, aún más importante,
a los gobiernos de los países en desarrollo,
a utilizar este modelo
para asegurarse de que las puertas de la educación superior
se abrirán de par en par.
Una nueva era está llegando,
una era que será testigo
de la superación del modelo educativo
como lo conocemos hoy en día,
de ser un privilegio para unos pocos
a convertirse en un derecho básico,
asequible y accesible para todos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)